you there what day is it it's Christmas
Day we've decorated our Rob with the
sweater which drives me a little more
crazier every episode but not as crazy
as soos and the real girl um bill on my
favorite episodes I love this setup uh
partially because you know this stuff
kind of happens like with some people
out there they become upside of this I
like I said probably a mile of episode
compared to like what other people do
with they I laughed so hard at this
because as somebody with an anime
background I'm like a Japanese dating
sim episode yes so no that's right
because I've heard these there's
actually like these oh yeah these games
that like it do they teach you how to
date or is it actually like no no it's
just about living out your sexual
fantasies no but yeah it's something
like that where it's like talk to a girl
and it's like would you like me to carry
your books or something no a part of it
or yeah it this was exciting on the
depending on the game you can do sort of
whatever you want so you can be a nice
guy or you know you can go to dark
places with it depending on who's made
man hell if it's an H if it's an H game
you can go to dark places with it let me
tell you the H stands for hentai um
tentacles but um no no it uh well I
laugh when they're like recommended by
nine out of ten basement dwellers I'm
like that I believe that's a bit of an
intro cuz if I'm not mistaken I think
the word otaku literally means basement
dweller oh really I'm Japanese yeah I
think so that's the Rossetti key Mori I
actually yeah I think I'm tired
otaku either means like house dweller
basement dweller or Kiki Moria is
apparently a harsher term that I I don't
know it anyway yeah I know I'm trying to
remember
welcome to the NHK and how it was Eddie
who okay so in this episode soos is
obviously if it's his mother his
grandmother um I always forget I
apologize blaming the comments after say
Merry Christmas
uh but I'm
readings this is diary yeah it is a
little to my soap opera yeah it's a
little too into what he's doing but uh
but teeth I'm assuming he was with her
right
or does she live with him cuz does tend
to have a job but it can't be enough to
support a house and she's got to have
like yeah that's gotta be like IRA
doesn't matter and so they live together
and she his cousin is getting married um
so she really wants him to get a date
and he's never bound a date before so of
course Mabel comes in and says she's
gonna help him out oh that reminds me
before I forget so last episode I missed
the swatch alert it was a unicorn and
this one is know this we got like three
dude anyway it starts off uh we get
sprinkles we get the soos shirt I just
always this sprinkles sprinkles
splitting counts and uh so we so we
start up with sprinkles then we get the
suit shirt where she misspelled like the
the Oh as I do I get on a mistake and
then she's got the reps shirt on at the
end of it this was a trifecta of Mabel
sweaters I hope it was a real swatch I I
keep track of like all the mysteries and
stuff I do you keep track of the sweater
so like that's the most important they
she dug some of us keep track of the
important things clearly um so he goes
and finds this game that was like wasn't
love Academy seven or something like
that and it's yeah apparently supposed
to help you to learn how to date uh yeah
but it was very close to dating since
I've seen it was a pretty good
representation a very dignified because
I'm just like where's option still scary
yeah I'm like where's option C stick it
in oh my butt so he goes all and he puts
his any gifts any comes across a girl
they Tiffany or is it confetti I never
know how to pronounce it alright so
close so I prefer giffany but turns out
she's this very advanced like
experimental uh device that
you don't even need that the Machine
point and as you put the CD and it's
like she will follow you everywhere it
should becomes obsessed and maybe live
because I was like well this is every
otaku's dream I can love you I you know
we can be together forever and I'm just
like you know there's a bunch of guys in
Japan or just like okay only one day
Japan I'm sure hear it
oh look well it was a creep from Archer
would be all over there yeah they all
suffer so if only I can make you
hologrammatic yeah hey that's where she
went so he didn't they became the
hologram yeah she did yeah she didn't
die she's not the first thing that goes
like I will make you real uh say I
wonder if that's like a little uh nah
the Hat to Archer you got a wonder cuz
it does look I mean I know a lot of the
enemy characters are very similar but I
mean it's like it is kind of the same
idea uh but so he finds out funny but
they finds a real woman on to get along
great and she's a little awkward too but
they get along really well and they
decide to go on a date this makes
Tiffany very upset starts to do really
all this cool stuff by going to the
arcade machine 500 Freddy's yeah uh took
over these Showbiz Pizza Show
animatronic which it coud owes for
making so who knows remembering showbiz
the 80s awareness this guy has
unbelievable yeah I know there's gonna
be kids everywhere like you know where's
right don't ya chucking Showbiz Pizza
yeah you Chuckie Cheese Showbiz Pizza
was better it's just that the pelvis
pizza was weirder it was definitely
weirder in Italy there's a documentary
about like what happened to show up his
pizza and I'm more curious to see it I
haven't seen it yeah show biz beats at a
weird southern angle and it was like you
had it was a billy bob baer and then his
side I don't remember the names I just
know but then the band the band in the
middle that's what made me laugh cuz I'm
like it what were they called the
Rockefeller explosion or something or
they had a giant gorilla named Fats who
was playing but they all look like the
characters and the one that freaks me
out the most was not only Billy Bob cuz
I was like that was a dead ringer Billy
Bob they put in there but though
cheerleader I'm like oh my god she was
in that band yeah
yeah justice Hugh Alex sir sir wood
whatever the creative team that they
told me remembered then I'm like sweet I
feel like I'm like seven years old again
and it's like 1986 uh so god world so so
she tries to split them up uh both
figuratively and physically I'm sure she
actually tried to split them um and I'll
distract them the children regard you
their children yeah I do love that cuz
you do can forget like oh yeah of it
they are just kids it's like she should
be protecting what um so finally throws
the CD into the fire and uh he I guess
kind of has a girlfriend but they break
out cuz she's going back to Portland set
which I didn't like I would have liked
if this case just cooked around yeah I
know it was nice and she was weird and
kind of awkward too but she was really
like you know pleasant that they should
kept her and it does a sweet character I
don't understand um but it made it maybe
they have better plans for him I don't
know um but anywho they uh and yeah
that's the episode um I like a lot of
great great references to stuff a lot of
like background text jokes like you know
like one of the magazine's was avoid
eye-contact a lot of stories was like
overalls are cute now the arcades life
avoider and back pat uh-oh the return of
the street fighter guy yeah fight
fighter that was great uh ha a new
challenger uh uh here's an interesting
thing I've seen this a couple times uh
when Stan is throwing out the old
animatronic thing uh there's like
they're spray paint on there that it's
either a muffin or a mushroom cloud but
it's popped up a couple times I'm kind
of wondering I'm up it wouldn't make
sense but if it's a mushroom cloud yeah
you got wonder if that's like a hint for
either what has happened or what's going
to happen cuz they keep talking about
like the end of the world it's a mystery
and with that's it okay the little
ending that they have here I really love
this one it says winning hearts by
daylight possessing robots by moonlight
her emotional baggage is real fright she
has the one named Tiffany she has the
one
Tiffany - Jojo that's great I'm not
gonna say what mood family that's
hilarious now you have to hate on Sailor
Moon is there anybody who haven't pissed
off in these V logs that's why people
watch them they're like who's it who
guys get angry at now you need to have
more fun look I have a moustache Berber
Berber Berber what I really liked about
this episode is it's very much like
people who do this will become oh I said
what the light goes on turned off no
it's draining my power now that you got
you got your like natural foods vacation
ear dirt churches joy to the world
nice uh-huh feel my power coming back um
so ya know there is something where it's
like every time I every time I see these
things like I hear these like sir
reference or talk abouts like on the one
hand I am very much like dude it's your
life do whatever you want but I'm also
kind of like you know okay it's not my
place to judge I don't want to judge but
I'm just like you know people care about
you dude I mean whoever you are dating
of whatever an anime character whatever
I mean it's like there's in this episode
shows it's like there's people out
there's so many variety of people and
yes some are probably harder to find
they have specific tastes that you have
but it's like dude it's big world out
there man and be happy the person or a
thug maybe some people aren't meant for
the world did you ever think that maybe
it's better that they're just fine in
their basement like there are definitely
people who are something like admitted
you've met maybe one or two people in
your life that you're just like maybe
it's better there in there well that it
they're happy and you know what the
world doesn't have to deal with
everybody knows one come on all of you
out there you know there's one but you
can't help and I know I get it they're
happy they're happy I mean they're happy
I'd be lying if I said I didn't really
yes but at the same time it's like you
know the far me that really cares and
it's like there's okay see if the crazy
part of me that has the sweater on and
goes nuts because the sweater talks to
me when outside would you think that's a
good idea
no what but I'm saying there's somebody
else why I go outside I take the sweater
off there's somebody else out there
who'll be just as crazy and maybe taking
that chance and going out there risking
it you can find that person
ladies I married si I mean I can see her
quite dress up like this yet but maybe
mix I'm trying to get her oh this will
be a Halloween concert Christmas and
Halloween just a boy that for
Thanksgiving there you go I'll be like
sweet christmas came early not going
there uh so yeah i love the creativity
as episode i love how she can go into
all these different machines i love the
angles like i love when that cheerleader
is walkie and you see her in the arcade
walking with her and stuff uh that was
great i love it i'll just my tie here
and bow tie i love the idea of having a
fight sequence a climax in a showbiz
pizza and all these things turn into
weapons like the ball pit and the goalie
on the slides taking the shoes yeah that
was awesome one more with that waking my
shoes off i vick was my girl wanted more
of that that's the one thing where it's
like looking great if like they followed
her in and they went through the tubes
it's amazing doing oh that's a girl be
fun oh and we're forgetting the greatest
line ever grunkle Stan opens a suitcase
filled with a flashlight rope and black
gloves and says hello old friends I
never thought I'd have to see you again
no more nights in Colombia no ya ain't
no more Colombian what would great oh
that's so funny
huh so yeah I really love this episode
it's a soos centered episode which we
don't really see either an
I thought was just a lot of fun it has a
great moral to it um it shows that there
are hope there is hope for those who are
just stuck to their convey their
computer screen um and yeah go go meet
people man you know it's it's or stay in
the basement I don't know I don't know
what's the you know the ethical choice
here cuz if you're happy whatever but
it's like you want man do we're right
for the universe if it's right for you
to leave and go then go oh yeah but if
it's better that you stay inside inside
the instance that somebody that wants to
be with you look after you it's just not
me okay but I still care about you
Wow I didn't go that far no no but it's
like there are people out there and it's
not me go away you'll find somebody I
don't have the patience but I do have
the caring to at least say go find that
perso you have the caring to judge
somebody to tell them to get them they
don't basement but say likes advise I'm
the adviser here I I don't know to in
voluntee let me get this straight I care
enough to tell to judge you and tell you
to get the hell out of your basement but
don't bother me when you do it yes that
that's the Christmas message that we're
getting across it's if you want more so
go home go go watch my other Christmas
video you want something like the mental
but nobody you know what I'm talking
about it so you do it's like yeah that
they're happy it's like okay that's one
and on the other hand it's like life
ma'am what beautiful life and it's book
weren't Chicago right now and it's that
mean technically I mean we're we're
doing this as a joke so it's like we're
five days ahead of Christmas but we're
in Chicago and it's steel grey skies and
30 degrees outside everything is dead
yes and you showed lecture me about
going outside and experiencing life
right now move to a better city if we
want to experience life and winter I
know it isn't it I guess an interesting
to pay cuz it's like is because I've
seen people that like make their living
online like on some of these interactive
games where it's like they never leave
but they seem to be in control
then see my violin is and they made a
business out of it that means I'm my
only thing is don't be a douchebag
like if you're living in your basement
and you're being a total freakin douche
bag
that's different then go outside get
laid
do something to stop being a douche bag
but if you're in your basement and are
completely happy and are nice to other
people and not a complete douchebag
fine by me you're not hurting me if
you're not hurting anybody I'm I mean
it's more on other animals you could
write you could very well be right I
mean it's like it lays it just because
somebody thinks it's weird doesn't mean
it's wrong if they're happy not hurting
anybody it's like fair enough I mean it
is one of those things that's like on
the fence about it
um I think you know you know what it is
I think when you feel like you're not
doing anything you feel like you you've
given up caring and you've given up like
oh it's just I'm not even gonna try but
it's like you didn't know I did I do
care but is that also overstepping a
boundary it's like going into somebody's
life and interfering where you shouldn't
interfere you know so it's like I'm very
down the middle on this well people have
to want to change though you're not
gonna be able to force them that's very
true but you always hear about that
person's like this person didn't give up
this person what was there but it's like
again it's always like this person
interfere with heaven I try to remember
silver linings playbook around it so I
all I can say is sitting here in a
sweater that says take me gnome tonight
in a Christmas wreath we raise your
lights and tinsel I'm not one to judge
yeah we really shouldn't talk so I'm not
going to judge but oh it's an
interesting conversation say the least I
know a lot of people Judea well it's
obvious you can go out there meet
somebody but it's like you sir said if
they're not bothering anybody and
they're happy it's like who are we to
judge over are we to say you have to do
this so I don't know it's isn't and it's
juice has a job you know what Hitler's
problem was nobody told him to go
outside and make friends maybe if
there's anything he was very bad at it
was motivating people and getting them
on his side is not out there it made
few more friends like say an entire
nations worth of friends he could have
gotten stuck you know people had just
said hi you know hi Hitler that's all he
wanted just people don't say hi this is
a great Christmas video you know today
the last day of Hanukkah or was that
technically gonna be yesterday it was a
Christmas Eve er because I know they say
sing daughter today yeah Merry Christmas
possibly Happy Hanukkah are dead i blur
yeah i it could be worse i think really
all things considered then less crazy
this time with the sweater so maybe
nothing is rubbing off on me I think I
think is their big offer maybe I'm not
becoming maple don't you think so dipper
I'm concerned Merry Christmas guys you
want more sentiment go watch the channel
awesome video